it's a customary commemoration but this
year more than ever a sense of loss and
absence
[Music]
the king now head of his family and head
of state leading the nation's
remembrance
he knows the routine that this is his
first time as monarch the king's wreath
newly designed and remembering the queen
with its Royal racing colors
a wreath two for the queen consort
and Prince William laying his first as
Prince of Wales
the Prime Minister also knew to the role
and another reminder here of the
transition of power
the veterans gathered to remember Fallen
colleagues including 100 year old James
Fenton been here on this occasion is so
very important for me especially at my
age because so many people haven't had
the chance to get here
to this point
and that is why they marched here
falkland's veterans marking the
conflict's 40th anniversary I wanted to
commemorate the amazing feat of arms but
I also wanted to remember
publicly and acknowledged publicly the
sacrifices that were made friends lost
and of course the families who who
suffer
and that suffering is by 16 year old
Aaron Nichols most people when they
think of the wars they think of World
War One and World War II and and older
people who are affected but it's
actually I was around 12 weeks old when
my dad was killed and it actually
affects young people a lot
Aaron marched with bereavement charity
Scotty's little soldiers today Prince
Harry wrote to them saluting their work
the service felt like another milestone
in the transition to a new monarch it's
50 years since he first made a reef at
the cenotar but here now is Sovereign
and the significance of the moment was
not lost on The King
the military and the Monarch have a deep
connection remembrance brings them
together and reminds us of their service
Laura bundock Sky News at the cenotaph